good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight russia is back in the news all
of a sudden we want to apologize to our
friends over at CNN we took a break
there was a moment when we weren't
talking about rush every day but for
tonight we're gonna read ress the
question of Russia collusion now keep in
mind that the premise of the now
discredited two-year-long Russia
investigation was that it was entirely
plausible indeed it was likely the
Donald Trump a former casino owner who
spent 14 seasons starring on an NBC
reality show was in fact despite all
outward appearances to the contrary a
secret Russian agent someone who was
working against American interests to
serve Vladimir Putin in Moscow that was
the claim and many of the non geniuses
in our media establishment clearly
believed it was true like endlessly
barking dogs they repeated that
allegation every single day for more
than two years because that's what they
do best but the much more interesting
and in fact important question has
always been this
what did senior law-enforcement
officials think of the story did they
really believe it was possible that
Donald Trump was working for Russia and
if so what evidence did they have and if
they had no evidence why did they open
the investigation and why do they
continue it for years every American
regardless of party has an interest in
knowing the answer to those questions
and so for more than a year the
Inspector General's Office that the
Department of Justice has worked to find
the answer today the report finally
became public and yet even before it did
some of the mouth-breathers on
television were happy to guess its
conclusion they proclaimed the FBI
completely innocent of all wrongdoing
because in 2019 being a progressive
means taking the side of bureaucrats
with guns no matter what the evidence is
watch the headline will be whether you
are a trump supporter or a trump skeptic
that the FBI is exonerated today from
the oft-repeated smear that there was
some sort of conspiracy to harm Donald
Trump's Kerry it's a big deal it's good
news no matter where you stand on the
political spectrum in 2019 now keep in
mind that when she uttered those
the FBI is exonerated today she hadn't
even read the IG report this is what
happens when you put former flax from
her spokeswoman on television and call
them journalists their job titles might
change but they keep lying in fact the
actual report was something of a
disaster for the FBI that was obvious to
anyone who actually read it even people
who work at MSNBC what it says is the
FBI basically repeatedly screwed up at
every level failing to pay enough
attention to potential problems with
steal failing to tell the Justice
Department the Inspector General report
says the FISA application was in many
ways inaccurate incomplete or
unsupported it says for example that the
FBI failed to look at some of problems
in Steele's past work that that was
never sufficiently addressed the FBI
failed to look at some of the problems
in Steele's past work well there's the
understatement of the week in fact
Steele so-called dossier was absurd and
that was obvious from day one no
legitimate news outlet would run it it
was so clearly false than even the
reckless Washington Post kept a distance
it was left to BuzzFeed to print it a
cat blog and yet the Obama
administration used the same document
the one that no one would print because
it was so obviously false they used that
as a pretext to spy on the Trump
campaign the dossier claimed that Trump
aide Carter page had been promised a 19%
stake in a Russian energy company a
bribe worth 10 billion dollars and keep
in mind when you're lying the more
specific the lie is the more likely it
is to be believed so the lie in the
dossier was he was offered 19 percent
not 18 not 20 19 percent interest in
this energy company if he could persuade
Donald Trump to lift sanctions against
Moscow now the claim was wrong it was
made up was false was a lie
page actually was a former naval officer
an Annapolis grad and it had done
nothing wrong and yet the FBI targeted
him anyway prominent figures on the Left
accused him of betraying his country
Carter paid his life was destroyed worst
of all and this is what we learned today
the FBI knew exactly what was happening
and they kept doing it
the FISA warrant against Paige the one
that allowed their bomb administration
to spy on him had to be renewed to
multiple times
and according to the IG report the FBI
repeatedly lied and excluded exculpatory
information in order to keep that Pfizer
warrant alive even after FBI officials
obtained information showing the dossier
was almost certainly unreliable again
something was obvious to everyone who
read it they continued to treat Paige as
a criminal and steal as a trusted source
meanwhile on television
the usual morons half-wits and partisans
continue to accuse Carter Paige of
crimes he'd never committed there was a
very clear belief that Carter Paige was
conspiring with Russia to in ways that
that were nefarious there was
overwhelming evidence to have probable
cause to do surveillance and Carter
Paige it would have been a dereliction
of duty for our FBI not to have sought a
surveillance warrant as you say it makes
a compelling case that there is probable
cause to believe that Carter Paige was
acting as an agent of a foreign power
imagine if that was you imagine if some
idiot former US Attorney Barbara McQuade
was on television day after day in
effect accusing you of treason and that
congressman and TV reporters all nodded
in agreement that sounds right the FBI
knew you didn't do it but instead of
lift the burden of suspicion from your
shoulders instead lied in order to hide
your innocence that was Carter Paige's
life for years it's hard to believe it
could happen in this country but it did
happen
let's hope Carter Paige spends the rest
of his life suing every one of these
people into bankruptcy and that list
should include malicious liars like
former CIA head and CNN contributor John
Brennan watch Brennan with a straight
face say something that we now know was
absolutely false
do you know who commissioned the Steele
dossier
I don't did the CIA rely on it
no one I because we we did it wasn't
part of the corpus of intelligence
information that we had it was not in
any way used as a basis for the in
of that assessment encounter page wasn't
the only innocent American caught up in
this witch on a witch hunt is not an
overstatement according to the report
say the FBI repeatedly employed
confidential informants and undercover
agents to collect intelligence on
members of the Trump campaign meanwhile
the bureau itself used a so-called
defensive briefing to monitor what the
campaign was doing now defensive
briefings are designed for the good of
the country the bureau shares
intelligence with leading presidential
candidates or presidents elect so that
at some point they'll have a grounding
on what's going on in the world when
they take control in this case however
the FBI used that briefing to spy on
Trump staff and to build criminal cases
against them can you imagine the IG
report claims that none of these abuses
were politically motivated now that's a
subjective judgment it's hard to know
but it's also hard to swallow that claim
only a partisan could believe something
as absurd as the steel dossier but let's
say the IG report is right and none of
these abuses were politically motivated
okay fine we'll grant you that does that
reassure you the facts remain the FBI
used flimsy excuses to spy on an
American citizen and monitor a rival
presidential campaign it repeatedly
engaged in abusive behavior to ensure
that that spying continued
illegitimately so it almost doesn't
matter what the motive for all of that
was the facts alone ought to scare you
this afternoon former FBI director Jim
Comey released an op-ed responding to
the report which you've likely seen
before the rest of us of course think
about that for a minute at this point
given what we know Comey ought to be
groveling for forgiveness from the rest
of he ought to be relocating to Paraguay
and shame actually but of course he's
not coming isn't embarrassed at all in
fact he's more self-righteous than ever
Jim Comey is a good person unfortunately
or not when he gets to have an alien or
seat on your behalf but you know there's
only so much he can do the FISA
surveillance approved by a federal judge
Comey tells us he'll miss the fact that
the FBI lied to the judge the FBI didn't
insert spies into Trump's campaign Comey
claims no thinest use spies to monitor
the campaign staff right okay and so on
like you'll never know the difference
Jim Comey doesn't think you have Google
apparently or more likely doesn't care
if you have Google doesn't care what you
know because they can issue a hundred
she reports every one of them exposing
Jim Comey as the sinister fraud he so
clearly is and he knows that none of it
matters because he knows he will never
be punished